nouveau numéro de reporter sur france 24
jamais la justice italienne avait tenu
un tel procès face au crime organisé
depuis celui de la mafia sicilienne cosa
nostra en janvier dernier il y à 11 mois
s'est ouvert le procès de celui de la
mafia calabraise la plus puissante au
monde la redoutable wrong et a la
particularité de la n'dranghetta c'est
qu'on y entre que par droit du sang il
faut au sens propre être de la famille
il est plus difficile de trahir un père
qu'un simple compagnons de route louise
malinois bonjour vous êtes notre
correspondante en italie vous avez
réalisé le reportage qu'on va découvrir
dans un instant les maîtres mots on les
connaît même si on ne parle pas italien
omerta et vendetta et oui ces règles
c'est demain il ya un homme qui les
connaît bien un homme qui a grandi sur
le territoire calabre est un homme qui
est allé à l'école avec les fils des
boss de la n'dranghetta de cette
puissante mafia il a été horrifié par
cette injustice aujourd'hui cet homme il
poursuit les mafieux il se dédie à
lutter contre la mafia il s'appelle
nicolas gratter rit aujourd'hui c'est
l'un des principaux procureur anti mafia
et nous l'avons rencontré pour ce
reportage alors on va découvrir ce ce
sujet avec effectivement des images
assez exceptionnel reportage tourné avec
lorenza penza et nathalie à mendoza
drang et à un procès pour l'histoire
[Musique]
le procureur nicola gratteri est l'un
des hommes les plus menacées d'italie
même dans les couloirs du palais de
justice il ne fait pas un pas sans ses
gardes du corps
je préviens capot mollahs et les autres
vous les avertissements adjugée pour 15h
au revoir président a plus tard
c'est lui qui représente l'état depuis
près d'un an dans le méga procès fait à
la 'ndrangheta la mafia calabraise
le groupe criminel le plus puissant
d'italie
je vis sous escorte depuis 1986 ces
dernières années les risques ont
augmenté
je pousse de plus en plus loin mes
investigations s'approfondissent et donc
la pression monte
on a dû renforcer mon escorte et mes
déplacements sont de plus en plus
balisée en cause
dans son bureau les visages des juges
falcone et borsellino assassiné par la
mafia sicilienne il ya 30 ans
plusieurs fois par semaine le procureur
prend la route pour le grand procès dans
sa voiture blindée
son engagement exposé malgré lui toute
sa famille elle aussi cible de menaces
1/2 fils fait de la moto et leur plan
c'était de tuer en simulant une sortie
de route de faire croire à un accident
pour l'assassiner
ce projet d'attentât c'est l'un des
prévenus du procès qu'il a révélé ici
dans ce tribunal improvisé sous la
protection de l'armée un bâtiment
industriel
la salle d'audience a été aménagée comme
une immense salle de conférence pour ce
procès monumental
bonjour m
cette salle mesure 3300 mètres carrés il
ya mille places pour ça les prévenus ne
sont pas ici on les voit sur ces écrans
il parle en vidéoconférence directement
depuis leur prison est notée
faire venir tous ces prévenus sur
l'année ça coûterait 50 millions d'euros
et sa mobiliserait dix mille policiers
agents pénitentiaires pour leur
protection et leur transfert à la pelle
cloud sur le tas
ce procès est historique
plus de 350 prévenu au sein de la
meringue état on ne parle pas la mafia
repose sur des structures familiales
très secrète alors obtenir des aveux
relève de l'exploit
il y à 42 repenti qui collaborent avec
la justice dans ce procès on a rassemblé
tous les détenus les plus importants qui
parle qui peuvent donner des éléments
sur la n'dranghetta qui connaissent ces
structures mais qui ont aussi
connaissance de faits de crime précis et
des informations sur les prévenant td
quest au ps
ces témoignages porter un grand coup à
la mafia la plus puissante d'italie
pour en arriver là il a fallu plus de
trois ans dans quête
à la caserne de vibo valentia les
carabiniers ont travaillé sans relâche
de jour comme de nuit
[Musique]
quand tout est calme comme ça il faut
être sacrément doué pour comprendre ce
qui se trame c'est la difficulté de
travailler sur ce territoire on essaye
d'avoir toujours un coup d'avancé
ils ont enduré de longues heures de
surveillance menés des filatures
délicate et éplucher des échanges
téléphoniques jusqu'à réussir cet énorme
coup de filet fin 2019 l'opération
rinascita scott signe 336 interpellation
le capitaine alexandre rouis pilote le
pôle des investigations il se souvient
de l'arrestation de domenico bonnaveau
tas après deux ans de cavale
on ne reste pas plus de cinq minutes ok
on ne doit pas attirer l'attention
la nuit' son arrestation on a encerclé
cette maison en entrant à l'intérieur on
a trouvé un tas d'autres personnes
disons que ce sont des complices pour sa
couverture lui il se planquer sous
l'homme qui se cachait sous un lit est
accusé d'homicide tentative d'homicide
et extorsion
il répond de ses chefs d'accusation
devant le tribunal ait fait face aux
victimes
[Musique]
simple commerçant car minepia a vu sa
vie transformée depuis qu'il participe
au procès comme témoin
impossible désormais de sortir sans ces
deux agents d'escort
vécu de chez moi au travail ça en vaut
la peine fallait que ça change ça
implique des sacrifices mais ils sont
nécessaires je m'adapte à mes nouvelles
limites le pape
comme la plupart des commerçants de nico
terra le buraliste a été soumis aux
pizzo l'impôt imposé par la mafia pour
avoir le droit d'ouvrir
deux paquets de cigarettes
je devais verser 15000 euros tous les
trois mois quand j'ai payé la première
créances on m'a dit que ça ne suffisait
même pas pour assurer le loyer
donc j'ai compris que ce serait une
histoire sans fin je vois plus loin
j'ai continué à payer jusqu'à ne plus
avoir aucun lien
chaque matin les menaces se faisaient
plus inquiétante arrivé à l'asphyxié
financière le commerçant se décide à
aller dénoncer ces racketteurs mais pour
l'après ma plainte les carabiniers ont
enquêté et deux mois plus tard ils ont
été arrêtés
on s'est ainsi opposée au clan local il
a perdu de nombreux clients
on lui reconnaissant d'avoir eu ce
courage parce que ce n'est pas facile ce
qu'il a fait
[Musique]
la dénonciation a été fait pour racket
extorsion extorsion
pour l'aider dans son combat carmine
zappia a sollicité l'aide d'une
association anti mafia les gentilshommes
[Musique]
jeux sont nombreux à être soumis au
brain drain guetta
alors il cherche à exclure et ça va
continuer
très souvent après la dénonciation il y
à un autre prix à payer celui de l'
isolement
à l'image de carmine et près de 2
millions de calabre aviv sous l'emprise
de la n'dranghetta
[Musique]
environ 150 clan 150 mg green et se
partagent ce territoire
à la tête du clan le plus puissant luigi
mancuso principal prévenu du procès il a
gagné le pouvoir grâce à son rôle dans
la construction du port de gioia tauro
dans ce port 7000 conteneurs débarquent
chaque jour un point stratégique pour la
n'dranghetta qui s'est imposé comme
numéro 1 du trafic de cocaïne
l'italie avec ce port figure en tête des
ports européens qui saisissent le plus
de cocaïne
parce que nous parlons de tonnes pas de
kilos
l'an 2020 notre unité a saisi environ 7
tonnes de cocaïne
les cargaisons arrivent d'amérique du
sud d'asie d'afrique du monde entier
ok les gars vous pouvez faire venir le
conteneur une quarantaine de conteneurs
seulement font l'objet d'un contrôle
contrôlée par ici on va regarder par là
à peine 10 à 15% de la drogue importée
est interceptée selon une source
policière
souvent ils utilisent la structure même
du conteneur parfois il peut y avoir des
trous des fissures
elles peuvent être bouché avec
différents types de marchandises de
provenances qui disent
c'est comme chercher une aiguille dans
une botte de foin et quand on la trouve
parmi les dernières saisies ces quatre
sacs à l'intérieur 108 kg de cocaïne un
butin estimé à 22 millions d'euros une
perte infime rapporté aux 43 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires annuel de
la n'dranghetta
des sommes qui aiguise les appétits et
attise des guerres de clans sanguinaire
dans le village de soriano le souvenir
du fils de martin aux chères à vau l'eau
est affiché sur chaque mur de sa maison
sa chambre est devenue un sanctuaire
on a conservé le billet de train
qu'avait pris philippot pour aller à
pescara voir un match de la joue la
tragédie est arrivé le jeudi 25 lui
devait partir le samedi à pescara mais
il n'est jamais absent de la cbn
le 25 octobre 2012 au soir
filippo chera volou quitte sa petite
amie pour rentrer chez lui en stop il
monte dans la mauvaise voiture celle
d'un mafieux pris au coeur d'une guerre
de clans
certains dominicaux tassone et
conduisait la voiture ils ont tiré sur
lui mais c'est mon fils qui a pris les
coups il a été touché là là et l'a 35
fracture ces types ont détruit une autre
ville
son fils a été reconnu victime innocente
de la mafia par l'état italien
un monument lui a été dédié dans son
village
pour moi cela représente beaucoup c'est
un symbole fort pour les jeunes c'est un
signal pour les faire grandir dans une
culture différente loin de la
criminalité
l' enquête sur la mort de son fils a été
classé en 2016 d'en avoir identifié les
auteurs des coups de feu martineau
espère qu'à l'occasion du maxi procès
des repentis apporte de nouveaux
éléments
[Musique]
nous avons rendez vous avec l'un d'entre
eux luigi bonaventura vous ne verrez pas
son visage il tient son adresse
confidentielle à des centaines de
kilomètres de la calabre
si je retourne en calabre je suis un
homme mort je dois prendre les armes une
vertu
il a été familiarisés à ce climat de
violence dès son plus jeune âge
tu es élevé au milieu des armes et toi
tu les prends tu les charges tu les
décharges tu regardes dans le viseur tu
tires c'est devenu un jeu
né dans une famille de bosses de la
n'dranghetta il a été éduqué pour tueur
à 20 ans il a commis son premier meurtre
puis à cumuler les crimes mais en
devenant père il a mûri l'idée de se
repentir
je voulais en parler à mon père pour
éviter de passer pour un traître je
savais que je prenais de gros risques
mais je voulais qu'ils apprennent de ma
bouche et pas par quelqu'un d'autre je
lui ai expliqué la situation lui
annoncer que je voulais offrir un avenir
différent à mes enfants et qu'ils ne
dépendent de personnes que la
n'dranghetta n'ait pas son mot à dire
sur ce qu'allait devenir mes enfants sa
décision du vote encore des menaces de
mort son propre père a tenté de le tuer
aujourd'hui l'ex mafieux livre sa
connaissance de l'organisation à la
justice
[Applaudissements]
il joint ses espoirs à ceux de la
population à vibo valentia où 86
personnes ont été interpellées 3000
calabrais sont sorties du silence ils
sont venus applaudir les forces de
l'ordre une preuve de soutien inédite
dans l'histoire de la calabre
[Applaudissements]
et on retrouve notre correspondante à
rome louise mal noah louise comment la
n'dranghetta tél assis son pouvoir au
delà des frontières calabraise dans le
sud de l'italie
alors la n'dranghetta aujourd'hui c'est
la mafia la plus puissante au monde la
seule présente sur cinq continents en
fait elle a profité de l'affaiblissement
de la mafia sicilienne cosa nostra dans
les années 90 pour grignoter un peu de
pouvoir un peu de territoire elle a
notamment placé des hommes à l'étranger
surtout en amérique du sud le but pour
eux c'était de gagner la confiance des
narcotrafiquants pour cela pour asseoir
leur pouvoir et surtout négocier les
tarifs les plus avantageux pour acheter
la cocaïne en fait la n'dranghetta
aujourd'hui c'est la mafia qui achètent
la drogue le moins cher jusqu'à 40%
moins chère que ses concurrentes la
mafia sicilienne cosa nostra ou bien la
mafia napolitaine la camorra et puis
ensuite cette drogue il faut la vendre
il faut ensuite blanchir cet argent et
cela se passe en dehors des frontières
calabraise ce blanchiment d'argent le
procureur nicolas d'une crainte et riz
nous explique comment ça fonctionne il
comble nos mains la mafia n'est pas un
problème propre à l'italie méridionale
c'est un problème qui concerne même au
delà de rome il s'étend sur un vaste
territoire parce que les mafias
s'organisent pour investir et blanchir
leur argent dans les villes riches pas
dans les villes pauvres du sud pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que la richesse se
cachent plus facilement dans une ville
déjà riche et ensuite parce que les
investissements ils sont plus sûres
alors les mafias achète en allemagne en
belgique aux pays bas en suisse et dans
le sud de la france
alors louis ce maxi procès qui a
commencé au début de cette année 2021
peut-il signé la chute de la
n'dranghetta alors éradiquer
complètement la n'dranghetta c'est quasi
mission impossible
on peut la comparer à une hydre quand on
coupe une tête sept autres repousse
alors les chefs de certains clans sont
aujourd'hui en prison mais il ya déjà
leurs successeurs qui sont en place
toutefois on peut remarquer que la
criminalité a baissé dans la province de
vibo valentia pour vous donner une idée
on a enregistré un meurtre depuis la
vague d'interpellations alors qu'il y en
a eu 18 rien que dans la seule année qui
a précédé toutefois cela reste difficile
de redonner confiance à la population
sur ce territoire par exemple
dans la principale ville rue de vibo
valentia ya encore beaucoup de commerces
dont les portes sont baissées parce que
les commerçants payer le pizzo 90%
d'entre eux payer le pizzo avant et
aujourd'hui ils ont peur de rouvrir de
se retrouver confronté à de nouveaux
clans alors le travail des associations
anti mafia devient essentiel pour
encourager la population à rester dans
l'économie légale encourager les
habitants à soutenir cette économie
légale pour que rien ne vienne plus
jamais comme avant
louise mal non à correspondante de
france 24 en italie merci louise c'est
la fin de cette émission merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter sur france 24
[Musique]